[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages
mit mitri sirin guten abend willkommen
an diesem samstag mit mir im studios
christian otto unter anderem gute
nachrichten vom winter schon macht lust
auf mehr und nimmt das haben wir unter
anderem heute für sie vorbereitet
neuer chef friedrich merz wird mit fast
95 prozent zum cdu-vorsitzenden gewählt
wachsende sorge wegen omikron drohen
schon im februar in vielen bereichen
engpässe auch in krankenhäusern
und in höchstform biathlet benedikt doll
gewinnt überraschend den letzten weltcup
vor olympia
[Musik]
sein weg war steinig und voller
rückschläge seit heute mittag ist er am
ziel friedrich merz wurde auf dem
digitalen parteitag im dritten anlauf
mit großer mehrheit zum neuen cdu chef
gewählt jetzt muss das ergebnis noch per
briefwahl bestätigt werden neben dem 66
jährigen entschieden sich die mitglieder
auch für eine neue führungsspitze über
die cdu neuausrichtung den neuen
opposition sound und einen sehr
gerührten friedrich merz winnie heescher
nimmst du diese wahl zum
bundesvorsitzenden der cdu deutschlands
an
hiervon freunde
[Musik]
ich nehme das wahlergebnis an
ich bin tief bewegt und beeindruckt von
diesem wahlergebnis
herzlichen dank für so ist das wenn man
endlich den job bekommt um den man sich
schon mehrfach beworben hat die cdu
stellt sich hinter friedrich merz und
wählten digital mit fast 95 prozent zum
neuen parteichef
märz hatte zuvor die union zur
geschlossenheit aufgerufen und
bundeskanzler urlaub scholz angegriffen
tonlagen wechseln in diesen tagen sorgt
sich nicht nur deutschland und europa
sondern die ganze welt um den frieden in
europa sie waren bisher weder in
washington noch in moskau und die
deutsche und die internationale
öffentlichkeit erfährt noch nicht einmal
ob sie denn wenigstens mit dem
amerikanischen präsidenten und dem
russischen präsidenten sprechen armin
laschet wurde verabschiedet sein alter
widersacher verspricht bessere
zusammenarbeit mit dem neuen cdu-chefs
tut uns leid
und es tut mir leid und es muss und wird
anders werden auch merz warnt wenn man
wieder regieren wolle müsse das streiten
aufhören
wenn wir uns streiten
wenn wir in alle himmelsrichtungen
auseinanderlaufen
wenn wir ein unklares bild abgeben
wenn wir bei den themen nicht auf der
höhe der zeit sind dann wird es
möglicherweise sehr lange dauern die
basis stärken herz den rücken auch der
neue generalsekretär
die fünf stellvertreterinnen und
stellvertreter erhielten durchweg gute
ergebnisse der nächste harmonie test
steht allerdings schon an der posten des
fraktionschefs
wir fragen nach bei theo koll in berlin
theo die cdu lag nach der wahl am boden
jetzt übernimmt er als sehr konservativ
gelten im märz die partei mit großem
vertrauensvorschuss was kommt jetzt auf
ihn zu nun märz muss so sagt er ja
selbst die inhaltlichen schubladen der
cdu wieder füllen denn die seien nach 16
regierungsjahren lea die partei müsse
jetzt wieder selbst denken zu märz also
da läuft offensichtlich die abnabelung
von der baake lehrer sowohl personell
als auch programmatisch vorbei märz die
partei erkennbar breiter und sozialer
aufstellen möchte als es seinen
bisherigen wirtschaftsliberalen image
entspricht gleichzeitig zielt er schon
voll auf die von ihm als schwachstellen
des kanzlers definierten bereich also
mangel an führung in der außenpolitik
und bei der impfpflicht der erste
lackmustest für märz der kommt dann
schon in zwei monaten wenn der reigen
der diesjährigen landtagswahlen beginnt
in der opposition gibt es jetzt nicht so
viele markante jobs theo stichwort cdu
fraktionsführung die hat noch ralph
brinkhaus in trotha bald der nächste
machtkampf also davon kann man ausgehen
jedenfalls hat sofort die diskussion um
den fraktionsvorsitz begonnen mehrere
cdu kreisvorsitzende haben märz jetzt
aufgefordert auch den fraktionsvorsitz
zu übernehmen mit dem heutigen starken
wahlergebnis hat es mehr als jetzt quasi
selbst in der hand wenn er den
fraktionsvorsitz will und davon würde
ich ausgehen denn es ist ja der posten
für maximale aufmerksamkeit als
politische opposition dann kann es ihm
ernsthaft niemand mehr streitig machen
auch der jetzige amtsinhaber ralph
brinkhaus nicht danke theo für die
einordnung und der neue cdu vorsitzende
friedrich merz ist gleich nach uns zu
gast bei was nun mehr vom digitalen
parteitag der cdu gibt es auch online in
unserer heute app dort können sie sich
auch die reden von merz und seinem
vorgänger laschet noch mal anschauen
während sich die cdu auf opposition
einrichtet stellt die spd bei ihrer
jahresauftakt klausur die weichen für
die wichtigsten politischen projekt und
man möchte meinen dass bundestagswahl
sieg und kanzlerschaft die genossen auf
wolke sieben befördern aber nicht alles
was die spd in der ampel mitträgt ist
automatisch auch die linie aller
sozialdemokraten mehr von andreas
huppert
gruppenbild mit kanzler vor der
klausurtagung der neuen spd spitze der
ort wohl gewählt der berliner eures
campus symbol deutscher ideen bei
energie und zukunftstechnologien zukunft
und energie auch zwei themenbereiche der
klausur
spd parteispitze muss einen spagat
schaffen zwischen regierungshandeln auf
der einen und der wahrung ihres
markenkerns der sozialen gerechtigkeit
auf der anderen seite die spd ist die
politische kraft die diesen wandel
beschreiben muss und die auch lösungen
anbieten muss die menschen sicher durch
diese zeit durchzubringen beispiel
energiepreise erst gestern wieder hat
die bundesregierung versprochen die
bekämpfung der klimakrise hat oberste
priorität der grüne energie minister hat
viele pläne doch die kosten wie also die
menschen entlasten die spd will jetzt
sofort die eeg-umlage abschaffen und
nicht erst 20 23 und somit zumindest
strom billiger zu machen ich gehe mal
davon aus dass alle koalitionäre die
aktuelle situation auch so bewerten dass
es handlungsbedarf gibt insofern kann
man auch dazu guten gemeinsamen
ergebnissen kommen das ersetzt noch
nicht insgesamt das konzept wie werden
wir diesen großen maßnahmen im bereich
vom klimaschutz auch finanzierung machen
für bürgerinnen und bürger sicherlich
eine der schwierigsten aber auch
wichtigsten aufgaben für den bundes
klimaschutzminister das gilt allerdings
auch für die spd sie weiß genau dass
regierungsverantwortung und
parteipolitische inhalte oft nur schwer
in einklang zu bringen sind
der klimafreundliche ampel kurs lautet
ja raus aus kohle und atomstrom das
passt nicht ganz zum eu-kurs atomkraft
als nachhaltige energiequelle
einzustufen darum lehnt die
bundesregierung genau das in ihrer
stellungnahme ausdrücklich weiter ab
befürwortete aber erdgas als
brückentechnologie
brüssels pläne gas und atomkraft ein öko
label zu verpassen sorgen seit anfang
des jahres für kritik zu corona da gibt
es fortschritte bei der booster kampagne
mehr als die hälfte der bevölkerung hat
inzwischen eine auffrischungsimpfung
bekommen die infektionszahlen steigen
weiter das rk ii meldet
135 1461 neue fälle binnen 24 stunden 57
1439 mehr als vor einer woche
179 todesfälle kamen hinzu die
bundesweite sieben tage incident steigt
auf jetzt 7
172,7
und der rasante anstieg der
neuansteckungen der besorgt auch viele
klinikärzte der marburger bund
befürchtet nämlich engpässe beim
personal und zwar schon in zwei wochen
die schnelle ausbreitung von omikron
sorgt auch in anderen bereichen für
probleme einzelheiten von volker
dutschek die omikron welle reist
zunehmend personelle lücken auch am
frankfurter flughafen immer mehr
mitarbeiter infiziert immer mehr in
quarantäne
die folge vereinzelte flugabsagen
wartezeiten betroffen vor allem die
flugzeug- und gepäckabfertigung
ähnliche auswirkungen auch in den
krankenhäusern jede zehnte klinik meldet
massive ausfälle 20 prozent mehr als
sonst im winter das ist das ergebnis
einer umfrage der deutschen
krankenhausgesellschaft die gewerkschaft
marburger bund hat sorge dass es
spätestens im februar sehr eng wird
wichtig ist deswegen dass die belastung
dieses personals das jetzt noch zur
versorgung zur verfügung steht nicht
noch größer wird indem wir jetzt die
kurve noch weiter ansteigen lassen
deswegen sind kontakt beschränkungen
weiter wichtig testen testen testen das
galt mal als leitmotive im kampf gegen
korona jetzt wo die test kapazitäten
knapp werden reist
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach das
ruder rum einen pcr-test sollen künftig
nur noch mitarbeiter der kritischen
infrastruktur machen also medizinisches
personal einsatzkräfte lehrerinnen und
lehrer menschen mit einer vorerkrankung
alle anderen so die
landesgesundheitsminister heute brauchen
künftig keinen pcr-test mehr
in einem zertifizierten testzentrum
darüber versucht man eben die situation
der belastung auch der labore
kapazitäten herr zu werden über diese
priorisierung werden am montag die
ministerpräsidenten und der
bundeskanzler entscheiden
der konflikt im jemen hat sich wieder
verschärft bei einem luftangriff auf
einen gefängnis sterben mehr als 80
menschen die organisation ärzte ohne
grenzen spricht außerdem von 265
verletzten die bevölkerung im jemen
leidet seit jahren unter einem
stellvertreterkrieg zwischen den
regional mächten saudi arabien und iran
im konflikt zwischen russland und der
ukraine will die bundesregierung auch
weiterhin keine waffen an kiew liefern
allerdings soll im februar ein
feldlazarett übergeben werden zudem
würden schwerverletzte ukrainische
soldaten im bundeswehr krankenhäusern
behandelt sagte
verteidigungsministerin lamprecht der
welt am sonntag die bundesregierung
müsse alles tun um die krise zu
deeskalieren in der ukraine selbst
wächst die angst vor einem russischen
angriff in der nacht sind nahe kiew
waffenlieferungen aus den usa
eingetroffen das militär ist alarmiert
die bevölkerung vor allem im nordosten
der ukraine verunsichert annafest
berichtet aus der kleinstadt serie
dönerbude unmittelbar an der grenze zu
russland
siri dina bruder eine kleinstadt mit
7000 einwohnern die hauptstraße führt
direkt zum russischen checkpoint
pandemie bedingt ist er geschlossen auf
russischer seite keine soldaten dafür
kameras roman katsch von der grenze
abteilung auf stippvisite
die männer wissen dass hier werde zum
schlachtfeld sollte russland wirklich
angreifen nachfrage ob sie denn
gewappnet sein
wir werden alles in unserer macht
stehende tun um die grenze und um diese
stadt hier zu verteidigen
keine 50 meter vom russischen grenze
zahn auf ukrainischer seite liegt die
botschaft von michael und seiner frau
ludmilla statt angst versuchen sie sich
in galgenhumor
wir werden hier zuschauen wie russen und
ukrainer sich mit raketen beschießen
aber wir werden in der mitte stehen und
nichts abbekommen
es sei ja ein einfaches leben das sie
hier führen arbeit gäbe es schon lange
keine mehr und nun diese verfahrene
situation erklärungsversuch ganz
standesgemäß mit wodka
es ist nicht die ukraine die krieg führt
gegen die russen sondern es sind die
amerikaner die krieg führen gegen
russland für michael hat die ukraine
wieder etwas in der nato verloren noch
in europäischen allianzen und er sieht
auch die ukraine in der verantwortung
schließlich würden doch auch die ihre
waffen auf russland richten kein wunder
also dass putin aufrüsten du kommst zu
mir mit krieg was soll ich tun ich werde
mich verteidigen das sollte man den
amerikanern und den europäern sehr
deutlich machen
europa solle sich genau überlegen wen
sie unterstützen schließlich fühlen sich
viele hier er den russen zugehörigkeit
dem westen
mehr naturschutz bessere tierhaltung und
faire preise die ampel koalition will in
der agrarpolitik umsteuern was auch
viele bauern unterstützen in berlin zog
das bündnis wir haben es satt mit
traktoren zum landwirtschaftsministerium
die forderung mehr tempo bei den
reformen damit auch kleinere höfe
überleben bundesagrarminister erste mir
sagte er könne die forderung eigentlich
alle unterschreiben die umsetzung sei
aber nicht einfach
wir machen mit dem schönen
erfolgserlebnis im biathlon weiter
so
passt genau tut alles gut für olympia
benedikt doll kommt 13 tage vor
eröffnung der winterspiele immer besser
in schwung im letzten einzel rennen von
peking gewann er beim weltcup in antholz
italien überraschend den massenstart
wettbewerb die entscheidung fällt beim
letzten stehendschießen der führende
norweger johannes teenies puffer fehlt
die letzte scheibe und muss in die
strafrunde während benedikt doll
fehlerfrei bleibt mit sieben sekunden
vorsprung geht das schwarzwälder in die
loipe und erreichte das ziel nach
grossartiger laufleistung mit mehr als
einer halben minute vor der konkurrenz
heute habe ich mir gesagt ich gehe
offensiv fand das ganz heran und
riskiere auch mal ein bisschen was und
ja es ging einfach auf und das macht
mich super glücklich
der sieger benedikt doll eingerahmt von
zwei norwegischen weltmeistern und
lagerei
und gleich zwei podestplätze verbuchen
die deutschen skispringer karl geiger
als erster und markus eisenbichler als
dritter beim weltcup in titisee neustadt
in der fußball-bundesliga hat borussia
dortmund vorläufig den abstand zu
tabellenführer bayern münchen auf drei
punkte verkürzt der bvb erkämpft bei
hoffenheim 1 3 2 leverkusen souverän 5
zu 1 gegen augsburg weiterer rückschlag
für menschen gladbach 1 zu 2 gegen union
berlin freiburg besiegt stuttgart 20 und
kräuter führt mainz 2 1 das abendspiel
bochum/köln ausführlich im aktuellen
sportstudio 23 uhr gestern unterlag
fahren von bielefeld 0 2 morgen leipzig
wolfsburg und hertha bayern münchen der
spitzenreiter und erfolgsdruck wohl
wissen dass verfolger dortmund bis auf
drei punkte heran gerutscht ist
leverkusen bleibt dritter union neuer
vierter auch freiburg rückt vor
hoffenheim in der unteren hälfte
gladbach als zwölfter nur noch drei
punkte vom relegationsplatz entfernt auf
dem feld augsburg unverändert am ende
stuttgart und kräuter führt und noch zur
handball em vor dem dritten hauptrunden
spiel gegen vize weltmeister schweden
muss das deutsche team in bratislava mit
sebastian firnhaber und christoph
steiner zwei weitere positive corona
fälle verkraften aktiv und engagiert ist
ja dabei gestern christoph steinert mit
vielen kontakten und einem tor der test
danach doch wieder positiv nach vier
negativen zuvor ein hin und her das
irritiert zwei niederlagen nacheinander
und dem bundestrainer stehen jetzt noch
15 spieler zur verfügung derzeit dabei
bräuchte es gegen schweden und gegen
russland 2 siege um im turnier zu
verbleiben die hoffnung auf rückkehrer
überschaubar ich weiß auch dass die
anderen nationen momentan keinen finden
konnten der nach dem fünften tag bereits
zu tun hier wieder stoßen könnte
training mit masken weil das virus der
härteste gegner ist
das zehrt schon alles und gemeinden
christin vielen dank für den alpenrand
da gilt eine unwetterwarnung wegen
starkem schneefall katja ohne fahrt
gleich mehr zum wetter um 22.45 das
heute journal mit marietta slomka hier
vergleich was nun mit friedrich merz wir
wünschen noch einen entspannten
samstagabend und sehen uns morgen wenn
sie mit
[Musik]
guten abend heute hat es ja kräftig
geschneit und auch jetzt in der nacht
schneit es hier am alpenrand noch
ergiebig weiter sonst fällt höchstens
ein bisschen schnee regen oder
nieselregen bei tiefsttemperaturen
zwischen +6 und -3 grad und morgen wird
er ein trüber tag vormittags kann es
noch ein bisschen schneeregen geben hier
in ostbayern oder auch in sachsen die
sonne sehen sie am ehesten zwischen dem
allgäu und der mosel und die
temperaturen steigen auf 2 bis 8 grad
die neue woche startet sehr ruhig es
gibt allenfalls im osten mal ein
bisschen regen und die temperaturen
liegen bei 0 bis 8 grad schönes
wochenende